WHY ARE THERE SO MANY TERRIBLE BLOWN CALLS
IN PROFESSIONAL SPORTS?
IT'S NOT YOUR IMAGINATION, AND THE REASONS
WHY MIGHT SURPRISE YOU..
HEY GUYS THIS IS ANNIE FOR DNEWS.
IN THEORY, SPORTS OFFICIALS ARE SUPPOSED TO
BE OBJECTIVE ENFORCERS OF THE GAME RULES.
BUT IN REALITY, THEY SCREW UP - A LOT. AND
IT'S MORE THAN JUST SIMPLE HUMAN ERROR - THERE
ARE PERCEPTUAL BIASES HAVING TO DO WITH EVERYTHING
FROM JERSEY COLOR TO HEIGHT TO PLAYER REPUTATIONS.
LETS START WITH BASEBALL.
UMPIRES IN THE STRIKE ZONE ARE WRONG ABOUT
14% OF THE TIME, ACCORDING TO A RECENT STUDY
THAT LOOKED AT 700,000 PITCHES.
BUT EVEN WORSE, THEY WERE MORE WRONG TOWARDS
THE END OF THE GAME - AND THAT THOSE WRONG
CALLS FAVORED STAR PITCHERS WITH REPUTATIONS
FOR GOOD CONTROL, ACTUALLY EXPANDING THEIR
STRIKE ZONES BY 16% ON AVERAGE.
SO, REPUTATION MATTERS.
NO HUGE SHOCK THERE.
BUT SOMETHING AS ARBITRARY AS JERSEY COLOR
CAN AFFECT CALLS TOO.
LOOKING AT NHL GAMES, ANOTHER PIECE OF RESEARCH
FOUND THAT TEAMS WEARING BLACK JERSEYS WERE
CALLED FOR MORE PENALTIES THAN TEAMS IN LIGHTER
COLORS.
THE STUDY COULDN'T PINPOINT WHY FOR SURE - WHETHER
WEARING BLACK ACTUALLY MAKES PLAYERS MORE
AGGRESSIVE, WHETHER IT'S A CULTURAL BIAS AGAINST
THE COLOR BLACK, OR IF THEY'RE SIMPLY MORE
VISIBLE ON THE ICE.
BUT EITHER WAY, IT AMOUNTED TO ABOUT 2 MIN
OF ADDITIONAL PENALTY TIME.
INTERESTINGLY THOUGH, THIS IS NOT UNIVERSAL
- A SIMILAR STUDY DONE IN A TURKISH SOCCER
LEAGUE FOUND NO DIFFERENCE IN PENALTIES BETWEEN
BLACK AND LIGHT COLORED JERSEYS
ALSO IN SOCCER, REFS ARE SHOWN TO CALL MORE
FOULS WHEN THE PLAY HAPPENS IN A RIGHT-TO-LEFT
MOTION THAN IN THE REVERSE.
THIS DIRECTIONAL BIAS HAS BEEN LINKED TO HOW
WE READ.
ENGLISH READERS, FOR EXAMPLE, PERCEIVE THINGS
THAT HAPPEN IN A LEFT TO RIGHT MOTION AS MORE
PLEASING BECAUSE IT'S WHAT MAKES SENSE TO
US.
THE REVERSE IS TRUE FOR READERS OF RIGHT TO
LEFT LANGUAGES LIKE ARABIC OR HEBREW.
ANOTHER STUDY FOUND THAT IN AMBIGUOUS FOUL
CALL SITUATIONS IN SOCCER, HEIGHT IS A FACTOR
- THE TALLER PLAYER WAS MORE OFTEN ASSUMED
TO BE AT FAULT.
IN BASKETBALL, STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT REFEREES
tend to favor home teams, teams trailing in
a game and teams trailing in a playoff series.
SO EVEN WHEN THE STAKES ARE REALLY HIGH - IT'S
CLEAR THAT THERE ARE MULTIPLE FACTORS THAN
CAN SCREW UP OFFICIATING IN MEASURABLE WAYS.
HOW CAN WE MAKE IT MORE FAIR THOUGH?
WELL, MANY LEAGUES - LIKE MLB THIS SEASON
- MAKE INTRODUCED INSTANT REPLAY RULES THAT
ALLOW FOR REVIEWING OF FOOTAGE ON TAPE.
BUT IT'S A CONTROVERSIAL MOVE BECAUSE IT INTERRUPTS
THE GAME AND AFFECT STRATEGY.
BUT WHAT'S WORSE - BLOWN CALLS OR ANNOYING
INTERRUPTIONS?
IS IT JUST PART OF THE GAME?
OR SHOULD WE JUST SWITCH TO ROBOTIC REFEREES?
AS ALWAYS LET US KNOW WHAT YOU THINK ON TWITTER
AT DNEWS OR ON FACEBOOK AT DISCOVERY NEWS.
ALSO CHECK OUT MY OTHER CHANNEL, WTBD, AND
YOU CAN FIND ME ON TWITTER AT ANNIEGAUS.
THANKS FOR WATCHING, SEE YOU NEXT TIME.